any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody to a special
summertime edition of the into the
impossible podcast
i'm your fearful host dr brian keating
the chancellor's distinguished professor
of physics at uc san diego and i'm
joined by another distinguished
professor from the university of
california
professor ben mazzine i don't think i'm
a distinguished professor i am the
worcester chair of experimental physics
though and ben is in town for a super
secret reason that we can't talk about
jason uh but we will maybe we will we'll
talk a little bit about that but i want
to expose you to the world of
experimental physics because we don't
get enough of that on the into the
impossible podcast because my
friends some of my best friends are
theorists ben i don't know uh i'll
forgive you
but they write these wonderful books and
very few experimentalists write these
books and because of that we have a bias
unintentional as it is towards our
brainiac friends including sarah seeger
who is recently in town visiting as well
now um i want to make the point that
there are many branches of physics
there's not only astrophysics although
that's what ben and i happen to do or
specialize in but within astrophysics i
claim there's no more
diverse
type of physics that you could do
because you have to do everything right
ben
yeah i think in astrophysics really um
it is the mother science you have uh all
all of science happens in the universe
right therefore it's astrophysics so i
do think it is the mother science and we
were talking over lunch about uh this
notion that you know kind of the the
prevailing
way that people think about astrophysics
is oh it just depends on things that are
out there but with the exception of
biophysics although now we're getting
into astrobiology maybe that is a part
of astrophysics so talk a little bit
about what you do the type of sensors
and detectors that you make and then
we'll get in we'll talk about aliens
which i think that you might be
forbidden to talk about all right sounds
good so
the work in my lab uh centers around a
technology called microwave kinetic
inductance detectors or m kids these are
detectors that
are extraordinarily uh sensitive
photon sensors we use them
in the optical and near ir where i work
because they give you unique advantages
over the conventional detector
technology like the cmos detectors based
on silicon that are in your cell phone
um
so
while the m kids these these
fantastically sensitive detectors that
can sense a single photon tell you the
energy of that photon and tell you when
it arrived to within a microsecond
without any false counts with no renoise
or dark current um so while those
detectors are the core competency of the
lab
it's the application of those detectors
uh where that gets that i think is
really exciting so what we do um is we
take these detectors we we develop them
from the ground up we're very vertically
integrated um in in ways that that very
few physics labs are so we do material
science to develop new superconductors
uh then we do condensed matter physics
to understand the um the detectors and
to make them into the best detectors we
can make then we put then we do
lithography and um and sort of standard
semiconductor process or semiconductor
type processing to make arrays of these
detectors we then take them in the lab
we do testing on them we iterate and
improve them and when they're ready we
package them up into
a camera and we build a big camera
around them then we'll bring that camera
to the telescope and we'll point it at
the sky and the thing that i'm most
interested in the thing that i point
at the sky most for is looking for
extrasolar planets so we're trying to
look for planets around nearby stars and
we're doing this
using a technique called direct imaging
so most of the techniques for finding
planets are indirect techniques where
you look at the influence of the planet
on the light of the star in direct
imaging you're trying to actually take a
picture of the solar system so you're
looking at light either reflected by the
planets or emitted in thermal radiation
from the planet itself this technique is
extremely technically challenging
because it relies on a couple a couple
very hard things the first one is
something called adaptive optics so
adaptive optics is a technique where you
um
look at a bright star and figure out all
the distortions that the atmosphere has
introduced into the light that's coming
to you and then you use a rubber mirror
so it's a
flexible mirror with pistons behind it
to correct for those distortions
thousands of times a second what you're
trying to do is remove that atmospheric
turbulence and give you this the same
kind of diffraction limited image you'd
see in space so that is complicated and
has a lot of a lot of ways to go wrong
the second thing you need is um
something called the coronagraph which
blocks the light from the star but
passes the light of the very nearby
planet and the third thing you need is a
science instrument that sits behind them
to collect this information and to do as
good a job as possible at distinguishing
photons that came from
the star versus photons that came from
the planet and that's where my
technology the m kids come in we
currently have a
20 000 pixel mkid camera the largest
superconducting uh array on the planet
at least maybe until simon's observatory
comes online um sitting behind this the
eight meters uh subaru uh observatory
telescope um behind the skexeo um
adaptive optic system in coronagraph and
um that um instrument is what we're
using to try to take these pictures of
these extrasolar planets the long-term
goal is it's not just to take pictures
of these planets but to use the energy
resolution that our detectors have the
ability to tell what wavelength every
photon is
to actually look at the spectrum of
light that comes from these planets now
if we look at the reflected light from
the star off a planet we can look for
atmospheric we can look for changes in
the spectra that are imprinted by the
passage of the light through the
atmosphere as it reflects off the planet
and that can tell us whether the
atmosphere is in chemical equilibrium or
not and if it's not we're going to ask
um
is that because of life and so that's
one of the things that we're really
aiming for it's going to take a another
generation of large telescopes for us to
get there we need sort of the 30 meter
class telescopes but that's our goal in
the next uh 10 or 15 years and if we had
a 30 meter class telescope on another
planet earth-like in every respect
including brilliant scientists like
yourself and your students
um how far out could could they detect
us how far away in our in our galaxy
could they see us so the bad news is um
we're not going to be able to see
um from the ground we're not going to be
able to see earth-like planets around
stars like the sun because the contrast
ratio the brightness of the star of the
sun to the brightness of the earth is
about is about 10 billion and so it's
it's really hard what we're going to do
to make it possible is we're going to
look at um
m dwarfs which are stars that are
smaller than the sun which means the
habitable zone gets closer and so the
contrast ratio between the star and the
planet shrinks to something like 10 10
to the 8 you know 10 million
100 million somewhere in that range and
that um and that becomes doable with our
technology so from the but because of um
the planets are so close to their stars
even with the 30 meter telescope we're
probably looking only out at something
like 10 parsecs which is about 30 light
years to um so it's really just our
local neighborhood you start to need
enormous telescopes to look out even
farther the galaxy is very very big yeah
the speed of light is uh very very slow
at least in some ways because uh there
was a tweet today from andrew raider or
radar i forget how you say his name i
mispronounce it the way i pronounce your
mispronounce your name all the time and
he just did a quick back of the envelope
calculation that suggested a grain of
sand from here at la jolla shores or
wherever um uh would impact a spacecraft
traveling at 99 percent the speed of
light maybe 99.9 with enough energy if
you agree with this calculation of
one-third of a hiroshima class nuclear
oh i could easily believe it yeah so you
know not only is the galaxy very big but
the speed of light is slow and yet it's
energetic enough to be dangerous kind of
like i am
but thinking about life in the universe
we've had on a lot of the discussions in
the past couple months on this channel
and other channels
about
extraterrestrial technology etc
first of all do you believe that there
is any kind of sense about asking
whether or not there is not only life
but intelligent life and not only
intelligent life but technological life
in the universe is that a sensible
question i think it's absolutely a
sensible question i don't think we have
much ability to answer that question but
i i uh i grew up on star wars and star
trek like everybody else in our my
generation and i'm of course fascinated
by these questions i would say that you
know i can say as an astronomer from me
to you guys um we've looked at a lot of
things in the sky with astronomy in a
lot of wavelengths radio optical
near-infrared x-ray gamma-ray
and we really haven't seen anything that
points towards uh
an origin that we that we that is uh
not explicable with natural phenomenon
so unfortunately i don't think we've
seen direct evidence of you know
technological civilizations modifying
their environments on
galactic scales at least if we did um
you know wouldn't that not change your
research direction in other words if we
had unequivocal
bayesian
high confidence credible evidence that
there are extra i know for me it would
change what research i do that's what
would impact you yeah no i i think it
would absolutely change at least the
flavor of what we're working on um i
i think my personal opinion with based
on very low evidence is that we're going
to find that single cell organisms are
going to be relatively common throughout
the universe i figure